[Música]
ooh
mírate en el espejo y llora lo que haces
cuchara a
alguien
[Música]
amigo
Oh
esta noche
[Música]
mi propio túnel de cohetes el dinero está en nosotros
celebra hasta que las lágrimas caigan de
mis ojos en alguien alguien
Oh
[Música]
todos los días intenta no intentar intentarlo
todo el mundo quiere dejar esto en un
segundo loco mi cerebro no tengo nada
desde que puedo creer que
sí
[Aplausos]
[Música]
alguien
Estoy bien, estoy  está bien,
algún día saldré de esta celda de la prisión,
seré libre,
una Rosa, cada vez que la ley extranjera
finalice el piano, la chaqueta en una Lamonica, la landeta, lave,
encuentre a alguien para amar a alguien, a
alguien, a alguien, alguien modifique
bien,
bien
[Música]
pero eso  también
Quiero decir
[Música]
[Aplausos]